a couple of years ago you decided that
you were gonna do the peewee character
but you thought I want to I don't want
to look like an older guy playing peewee
I made a movie a few years ago for
Netflix that was a third peewee movie
there was like a 25 year gap and and I
felt like being pee-wee Herman at that
point or now or later was sort of like
you know the movie whatever happened to
Baby Jane yes it was sort of like I'm
writing a letter to peewee you know it's
like like scary like I just like weird
right um right so you know peewee was
sort of based on youth and youthfulness
so we did something this is a secret so
please don't tell anybody this okay it
won't get out on this show so we did a
early computer-generated sort of like
the Irishman do the same thing yeah we
did the same thing and I was prepared to
talk all about it in it when when the
movie came out
but people the press saw the movie and
would say stuff to me like what is your
secret my god it's like time Stood Still
and I would be looking at the people
going your two feet away from me what
are you taught you just saw the movie
anything like that right no I think
people just thought we had a big budget
and I had an Academy Award winning
makeup artist which I did a lot of
backlighting yeah high angles so how
much tummy because on the Irishman I
heard that took a lot of time they gave
you a younger face what is that what's
involved I mean you couldn't afford it
really seriously it's if you have to ask
you know seriously though I'll tell you
certainly I don't have that problem I'll
be the judge of that
[Applause]
what do you think I would consult
someone tomorrow I mean get work
immediately tonight if you can
interestingly enough and I I found this
out in hindsight it costs so much money
to do it that it would have been a
fraction of the cost for me to have had
plastic surgeon really our extension the
extensive complete new face right right
that would have cost less than all the
CGI work they did consider I could have
had six facelifts have you ever
considered franchising the peewee
character meaning finding an actor a
young actor who does it well and and and
giving them the outfit and saying you go
out you do the peewee stick and I'll
make the money off of it absolutely it's
currently for sale right now I have an
ad in LA Weekly online with the Conan
the Conan character I want to sell I
want to find some young strapping kid
and and and put him in the wig and you
know teach them a couple of moves and
say go out there be Carla Brian I got
60% see
when you finish with that put on the
pee-wee's stuff and do peewee yeah or we
sent a Conan out in a peewee and they
frolic and we make the dough see ya
I feel that if I could pull that off I
could become so wealthy it would be
incredible if I sold the peewee
character for what I believe it's worth
I mean it's quite a bit of money yeah
and I would be like you know right rich
like King Midas rich and I would I'd be
so rich I would own this studio I could
buy your contract
I could I could take over the show to
become my show this would be your show
Paul O'Brien I would no one wants to see
the Paolo Brian show well we'll see
about that did a camera just go out for
a second I thought I saw I didn't notice
oh I thought I saw a little cameras yeah
what this is been on television the
whole time stop-in yes what a cruel joke
it's over the cruel prank